- The joint resolution is passed.
(gentle music)
- [Narrator] Congress approved
legislation that would force
the adoption of a
tentative labor agreement,
averting what could have
been a massive rail strike
involving about 115,000 workers.
(train horn blaring)
Unions and railroad carriers
came to an agreement
in September to avoid a strike.
But four of the 12 rail
unions rejected that contract,
citing specifically a
lack of paid sick days.
But how can Congress
intervene in private contract
negotiations, forcing
unions to accept a deal?
(ambient music)
Thanks to the Railway
Labor Act which was enacted
in the 1920s, Congress
has the authority to act
to avoid any interruption
to commerce or operation
which specifically includes
the settlement of all disputes
when it comes to things like
pay and working conditions.
Freight Rail moves about
40% of US long distance
cargo and delivers goods including
coal, grain, and ethanol.
And three-quarters of new cars and trucks
bought in the US are also moved by rail.
Industry analysis shows that
if a rail strike took place
the US economy would risk losing
more than $2 billion a day.
President Biden, who has
hailed himself as pro-labor,
encouraged Congress to
pass the legislation.
- It's not an easy call, but
I think we have to do it.
Economies at risk.
- [Narrator] Members of Congress,
however are divided over
the decision to intervene.
- It's incumbent upon
Congress to do everything
that it can to protect these workers.
- If you're passing a bill
to force the rail workers
to work, how strong is your economy?
- [Narrator] This isn't
the first time Congress
has stepped in, they've done it 18 times.
But not since the early '90s when Congress
and President George H.W.
Bush passed legislation
ordering workers back to
their jobs, and then created
mandatory arbitration
which has long alleviated
Congress from getting involved.
But this time, because that
arbitration wasn't agreed on
Congress acted earlier.
Hampering workers' ability to go on strike
and forcing the acceptance
of the agreement
which will last until the end of 2024.